これじゃあ肇社長です皆さんあんっ
好きですか
明日木急ですね僕も好きなんですそういえば去年なんですけども-23が菓子パン
ランキングやってましたよね
確か1位から5位はこんな感じだったと思うんですけども
俺をやりたいですただ文化パンのランキングをつけるだけじゃなくて今回は企業がヒマ
やってみたいと思います
的で止まずにのか出版なですねご覧くださいこちら
何度も100種類以上あるんですよ素晴らしい皆さん食べた百済菓子パン絶対あると
思うんですけども
大量の価値番手山崎パンやっていきたいとおもいます
それだけにまずは1種類ずつしっくりとはじめしていきましょう
と言いたいとこなんですけどもさすがにこの種類を味見するとそれだけでお腹が
いっぱいになるので今回は15種類の人気の歌手 sunday
山崎パンやっていきたいと思いますこの15するでたぶん皆さんも見たことあるやつだ
と思うんですよ
実はやり方としますがさっすぐにそのままこんなの価格で食べたらわかると思うんで
おいしすぎるんでパンのつ
じゃあな生地とあでも僕は彼と思うんですよ例えばカレーパンですよ
こんなのカレーの味が写真がすぐこれだってわかるんでそんなレフだ僕はしません
apple 下手もちょっとした記事を食べてアップルパイと当てたり
こうあっパンとかもあるんですけどももさーんまで行かなくていいでファンの僅かな
基地ちょっとしたその記事で僕もん当てられると思うんで出来るのかな
ちょっと不
中身の具材とかじゃなくても記事からも全然違うと思うんでそこで開けて行きたいと
思いますでは行こう
はいという上でまずは15種類の味見をしていきましょう
視界がそのままの生地の味のインプットするのがめちゃくちゃ大事だと思いますパンの
生地
わかるかなぁまずはこちら北海道チーズ蒸しケーキ
呼吸をするようにた
ていましたいただきます
ねぇえ我はさすがにわかると思います
牛乳と食べても美味しいんで皆さん是非食べてみてください
上屋ウェズねこちらイチボスペシャルでございますね3分食べ物ありますどんなにこの
中に15が詰まってるか
毎日家でからイチゴとあっクリームが絶妙な松井稼がめちゃくちゃ美味しいです15
いちご農大に浮かぶんですイメージが欧州の音まちなみに売ってる素敵ななんか
スイーツのお店に売っている
イチゴケーキの味がしますね甘い本当にては大きいですよねサイズがすごい満足感が
ある
ボリュームだと思います次じゃあこれ行きましょうかこちらまるごとソーセージで
ございます
北小学校のときバスケットボールのクラブみたいなの入ってたんですけども
バスケする前にいつも食べてたのがこれでしたねまるごとソーセージ
いただきます
[音楽]
完全にバスケ思い出しますこれもう
バスケットボールの感じだったらもう孫女装先生間違いないけど
懐かしいずではこちらチョコチップスナックですほらね高校の時によく食べてました
何度友達に12本3本ぐらい奪われたか
ああなんか普通に高校時代を思い出してやや泣きそうロっぽいなぁでなが後からも
食べるしみんなと食べれるって言うのも常時ぷジャックの楽しみ方だと思います随時
こちらです薄皮つぶあんですこの薄皮つぶあんぱんですねあの家の全体が滅茶苦茶すぎ
ねすごい
買い込んでて毎日食べてたんですけどもそれを張れずに僕食べてました
じいさんごめんなさいいただきます
何のパンがねこうちゃんとサポート役に回ってしっかりと粒あんを立たせてるっていう
聞いたて役に回ってる感じですごい
絶妙な味のハーモニーを生み出しますじゃあ次はこれいきましょうかちょっと r
つながりで高級すぐは薄カープ doors どう使うんでしょうか
いただきます
ああ
うーんまあ俺あーん好きなんかなこの年になってなんか
あんこが好きなのかってことに気づきだした気がするうスカート比べでふっくらしてて
そこがめっちゃ美味しいですね美味しいですありがとうございます
水ではこちら経営起動な2ですでも僕は個人的ななんか青春状態の問題かもしれないん
ですけどもなんかどうなって食べてる男観光言うみたいな変な妄想がって高校の
できます
なんか知らないけどこの経験がなくめっちゃ食ってたんですよねほんと高校時代の黒
歴史を思い出しだろう
うーんそれではこちらコッペパンですね
超ロングセラー商品山&マーガリが絶対良く見えたらされてる気がするんだよな
オペ音が良いが入ってくる可能性はありますねいただきます
懐あよルーンまあやぐちっくパワーだかジョブと曲がりが一番美味しいみたいなところ
あるような気がしていくちゃうから嬉しいですねこれ
web と止まらなくなりますちょっと行けますそれではこちらミニスナックゴールド
です
うわこれねウチの実家にあったねー
それぞれがそのお菓子の時間あけてもいいボックスに入れられていた気がしますこれ
なんとで外ことやこれ
めっちゃくちゃ次回もピザ1枚くらいで今日いただきます
うまいとか甘いなるくるわーさん的な記述芸美味しいですね
このうにゃにあってかかってるシュガーシロップがめちゃくちゃ美味しいです
あの中じゃ前実家に帰りたくなってきますこれ食ってると思う
うわぁ懐かしいホワイト地に出生ことですこれを小学校のバスケっていう時に食べて
ました
小学校のバスケのはクラブ初丸前に食べるパーンてを
母さまがランダムに決めてたんで様にこのホワイトてに者庄原入ってて
この時は願って甘いからなんかもを誘致たのが落ち着いちゃう感じでちょっとバスティ
どころじゃなかったですね何の話をしてるんだ俺は懐かしいこの中にね
いたツボっぽいのが入っているところがすっげー美味しいんですよ
単語記事がすごいふわふわしてるんですけども一発
が結構しっかりしててそこのこのね高低差と言いますか
母の中の方っていうギャップが凄い特徴的です
次いでこちらふっくらバーガー完熟トマト風味ソース&マヨネーズ
俺これから見たことあるけどされたことないんですよねハンバーガーもない好きなんで
将来アメリカに住もうと思っている私でしたら
絶対美味しいはずねせていただきます
[音楽]
are you say
これは usa ナッパになるこの手の奴はね電子レンジ絶縁したら美味しくなるん
ですよ
tee
丁度良い高さになりましたいただきます改めていただきます
にゃんんまトマトソースがめちゃくちゃ美味しい
やマヨネーズと松園詰め合わせはまず最強さ続いてはアップでたいです
アップルパイねこれも結構三かけてたんですけどそんなに食べる機会はなかってくるし
ますね
は注ぐベッツ生地がしっかりしている
いただきます
前はリンゴもとってもフレッシュですさあ記事だな
記事勝負となるといえばちょっと端女だからこれは覚えておきたいところでありますね
釣りでカレーパンですこれを僕よく見かけてないんだしても食べて来なかったですね
カレー大好き芸人の私果たして山崎パンさん当たればどんなでしょうか
えっ
あーんまやっぱりすごいちゃんとうれしいなじゃあもう結構はカレーパンにうるさい方
なんですけど
からともなく甘くもなく誰でも最初見える絶妙な辛さのポイントをしっかりついてきて
いるカレーの辛さだと思いますすばらしいですそして古謝スイートブール
会かぁ何回でこれ見たことあるんですよでが過ぎて何買って来て食べてこない
あっですごく人気なんですねちょっといただきます
でっかい呼ばれ誕生日ケーキぐらいありますけど
[音楽]
def
なるほどねーライブ人気でしょパンの前方のこれを佐藤かな
コーティングされててめちゃくちゃ美味しいです
[音楽]
そして15職員の最後の逸品歓迎してましたよどっちだ
ないですねええファンの玉柄がナイススティックこんなインパクトあることないですよ
そしてこの長さめちゃくちゃ特徴的ですいただきます
あめっちゃスジ肉
[音楽]
ナイススティック何が美味しい事言いますとこの細いカードに秘められている
一つクリームこれはジェルにパンとマッチしてていいんですよね
そのなぜこの方さあだからこその多いしたみたいな感じがあって
本当に唯一無二のファンだと思っていますナイススティック
はいど部で15つ0の山崎の菓子パン食べ終わりました
なぜ3した感じなんですけどもう全部術においしかったですサブだけで満足なんです
けれどもそれがとつまらねぇ
というわけでここから聞き山崎パンやっていきたいとおもいます
重合する位のうちのどれか一つめちゃくちゃ小さいサイズでもらうんでもうその記事で
当てます必ず
家を綺麗な特徴もある程度頭にもインプットできてるんでどんな記事が来てもわかると
思いますでですねこれ外すと何が起こるかといいますと
外した政界のパンで即興で
歌わせて頂きますはぁ
お姉さん僕ドイターなんでそうないですからいやでそれで混ぜしかないんでよろしくお
願いします
ろしくぉ見えません何もではん
一文でお願いしますはいよろしくお願います矢部イベントにヤバイから本当に外しあげ
ないでは一応女はい
でもう撮った載せましたこれですねはい
いただきます
ちょっと分けしっ
本当にちょっとだけヤバいですええやまず一問目上げ当てたいなーっ
もう一口もう一口お願いします見せましたまじんですか
軽くとわからないよ
いただきますってっ
内接ていくもとか耐久数秒なあの細身の体を維持するにはもうちょっと外壁を稼がない
といけないけどすぐ
ととなりました5問目の答えははい
ふっくらバーガーです
明確使用ください
残念ですね
さーん車だけで方へとペルシャベロビーチ
ブーブアイフォワイドデーに一瞬たいよプーリー入ってるよパーン4分ちゃ
だいつもねちょっと残念な結果に終わりましたが次はそうもいきませんよ
宜しくお願いしますはいこちらですなるほど
いただきます
あまえんはいはいはい
はい書庫ジップスティックを開けください
fan じゃあザーン
ええええよ出せこそせずブシェ切符チーズる死刑いっぱいみんな大好きだよ
北海道いかなくても北海そう私です
ボカロぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー寄付みんな大好きだよ
えおこれめちゃくちゃ好きなのに
や悔しいですこんなもんじゃありません盗んでいきましょうはい
こちらですがとうございますいただきます
まあこれはた釣り分かりましたもうあなたの姉違うでも質が
ケーキドーナッツを開けください
3年さんに b 5 a a
ねーばいばいふっ同伴パーサー
バイ
はいはいウルシ科は2
はい ran
厚さあんなんでじゃー
育児あシーンだけど者さんこれ難しすぎるんで次ちょっと扇うねってるんですかっと
ケンケンちょっとやってみてください
むずいですよ本当に check 4
白でいきたいとおもいますいただきます
[音楽]
ハマって美味しいぞはいはい
1月めちゃうお聴きください
[音楽]
yeah
いやさすがねこれはねーなったこれは文字や竜の恩人は次もうと小さないじめちょっと
次ちょっと小さめでてみましょうこちらですなるほどそれか
んね私はされたのは
スポジップスナックファイナルアンサーファインダーランチャ
大木ください
すごい
続ぎましたやなぁ
ちょっとぜひもう立ためできるでしょうかこちらです
いただきます結構小さくなりましたねー
のことソーセージっぽいなんかバス
とボールをたたいて男性をしました
丸ごとソーセージですお書きください
[音楽]
さーん
22位1
はいはいスイートブールスイートプールバーン t 4 er
twitter 土井来たいな d は hulu
いやスイートぶりでわからなかったの結構辛いなぁ
てくださいいただきます
雑貨3的な右があっ
はいナイススティックです
ミルキーを感じましたはいせーなー
すごいマッサージ感じた今ミルクを盗んでいきましょうはい
tan
これでいきますでもどうぞいただきます
敵を感じるな1の製作しそうな気もしないああ
まずでも感じと anan を感じましたね8薄皮つぶあん終わっているとなると
私が今食べたのは高級生はを開けください
これは自信あん
プーちゃんねんあんぱんです誰誰で15スレにいましたこの人さーん
ねーよ h
はいみんな大好きアンパンで早いぞ
今日も元気に風しよう
ああ
俺12最大5個を食べたことあるよ
なかったよこれが美味しいですよさあならねえあの
徳光
ゲストねでこれだけの高級つぶあんとは違うあっ
15世に入ったとのこっちで今撮っちゃってきた酢酸に紛れて来ていただいたのがこの
あんぱーん
こしあんが使われてるんですねそれは分からずいただきますね
ブーブー
まし論文も
こちらのなかなかワンド感じがしますめちゃくちゃお茶と一緒に食べたい逸品であり
ますねこれ美味しかったです
ありがとうございますでも問題にはなかったぞ
アイテムで聞き山崎パンや釣りたわけなんですけれども
な難しかったですね少ない量だと本当にわからなかったんですけども
ちょっと大きくなったさすがに分かりましたけどもじゃあまずスパーさん全部美味しい
なって思いました
本当にたくさんぱ別しますそうですだけでこの15世の中からの僕の攻めのファン5
種類
骨やねいちごスペシャル
北海道チーズ蒸しケーキ定期ドーナッツたぶん初めて食べたんですけどおいしかった
ですアレイパーン
そして大雪ティック以上の御品になります
そして山崎パー3乗り場にはこういうポップやシールが貼られていますのでみなさん
ぜひ探してみてください
皆さんもぜひ山崎パンを食べてみてくださいじゃあなー
el
[音楽]
うぇっは